Islam hates women. Imagine following a
religion that teaches majority of hell
is women. You know what? I'm going to
call him now.
This is one ummah Sadaqah Jariyah video.
If you care about the dunya more than
the akhirah, skip it. By one donation,
you're going to help 1.8 million people
in need. 551,000 people who've been fed
through the emergency food aid. You are
going to be sponsoring 4,200 orphans.
You will be helping 250,000 people in
Gaza. You'll be helping 123,000
people to be fed through our Qurbani
program. You will help feed 551,000
people through the emergency food aid.
56 masjids are going to be built around
the world. And 74,000 given clean safe
water. That's why we want to keep One
Ummah 100% donation policy. And in order
for us to keep it 100, we need you to
help us by supporting this fund so that
all of the stuff that I mentioned, you
get the reward for every single one of
them. It's far more important than the
dunya. And you will see every penny that
you give on Yawm al-Qiyamah. The
decision is yours. The link is there.
Donate.
wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh, brothers
and sisters and dear friends. Came
across a video of sister Lily Jay.
May Allah bless and preserve her and
protect her and her family against all
hate and may Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
allow her, enable her to get closer to
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala in every way,
both um
externally and internally. Uh and um she
recently sent a message regarding the
video that I had done about her and her
daughter. Uh uh thanking me. And I'll be
honest with you, um I I was happy to see
that. Why? Because uh there's this smear
campaign that's done against myself
mainly that I'm a misogynistic etc. So,
it's very it's it's happy to I'm happy
to see that she sees right through that.
Subhanallah. And this label that it's
very interesting. I get sisters
sometimes come to the table and they're
you know, brother, you're harsh or you
say this misogynistic. And I'm like,
sister, where have I said something
misogynistic? Dead silence. They tried
to cancel one of my university talks,
these radical munafiqs, yeah? And I
asked the pre- uh the president. I said,
bro, go and ask them to give one one
reason, to show me one thing that I said
misogynistic.
Dead silence. Nada. Nothing.
Alhamdulillah. Okay? So, subhanallah,
you can see the smear campaign. It's
like Islamophobes. Islam is violent.
Islam is violent. Islam is violent.
Okay, where's your evidence? Hmm, it's a
smear campaign. But, I want to watch
this video, inshallah, cuz this shows
you and I tell brothers, don't ever
reject the sister cuz she doesn't wear
the hijab. Cuz some sisters who don't
wear the hijab, wallahi, sumbillahi,
warabbul Kaaba, have more modesty, more
haya, same thing. Yes? Okay, the way
they carry theirself, their only trial
is what? The hijab. And that's why I
never ever And people are going to be
shocked when they hear that. I have
never ever attacked any woman who took
their hijab off. Abadan. Even the
non-hijabis. Watch my video. And don't
even say that. I say just don't
encourage others to take their hijab
off. But, watch this video because this
is so powerful. The hadith of the
Prophet Muhammad, peace be upon him,
that majority of the inhabitants of the
hellfire he saw was women. Look how
Lilly Jay, she could have easily come
and say, "No, I reject this hadith. This
hadith is wrong." These nifaqis who wear
hijab,
hijab, yeah? For God knows what reason.
Okay. Okay, if you wear the hijab for
the wrong reasons, yeah? If you wear the
hijab cuz you're going bald, yes? Okay,
you're not getting the reward. Yes? Your
reward is if you're wearing it for the
correct reasons. May Allah subhana wa
ta'ala make it easy. But, these nifaqis
who wear niqab and hijab and some of
them are non-hijabis as well. Okay, look
how they respond. And look at this
sister who's a revert to Islam. Look at
her reaction that someone will pick on
her and be like, "Lilly Jay doesn't wear
the hijab. She doesn't wallahi, she has
more grounding in Islam than all of
these nifaqis put together. These are
feminist radical nifaqis." Watch her
reaction to it. Islam hates women.
Imagine following a religion that
teaches majority of hell is women. Have
you even read that hadith? Context
matters. It says that majority of hell
will be filled with ungrateful wives.
And yes, that does sound a little bit
harsh, but it's not even that hard to be
grateful. Look look look what she's
done. Look what she's done. This is what
I'm talking about. And there was another
sister that I saw who was looking for a
video. Non-hijabi. She was like, "Yo,
listen.
Did the messenger of Allah say that?
Khalas." I was like, "Yo."
So, you brothers, give you an advice.
Don't ever ever turn down a sister cuz
she doesn't wear the hijab.
Wallahi, and I'm telling you look I'm
telling you look you're going to tell me
oh brother that's easy for you. I
promise you when I was looking to get
married, there were two or three sisters
that did not wear the hijab that I was
looking concerned to get married. My
only condition is they pray salah. They
don't pray salah, sorry. I don't care
any hijabi
niqabi whatever you are non-hijab no no.
Salah is a key. No salah, sorry. So, I'm
practicing what I preach, yes? Okay, and
if it alhamdulillah I'm married. My wife
who wears the hijab. So, the point is
what? Look look at her reaction. And she
didn't and the Ansari woman the Prophet
the Ansari woman didn't come and say,
"Oh messenger of Allah we don't like
that how how dare you majority of the In
how far how dare you?" No.
They were believing women.
True believing women. And the Prophet
gave them a solution. Gave them a
solution doing sadaqa
etc. etc. etc. Gave them reminders and
said, "Look this is what you should do."
And they submitted to that. And you know
what? It shows us the reality because
women can be I'm not saying all but a
lot of women can be ungrateful to their
husbands. And the Prophet is telling us
this reality. As men we have certain
traits that we are warned against. Yes?
Okay? And we are warned against it. The
very fact the Prophet said, "Now I feel
nothing for the ummah the men except the
fitna of women." It's a reality that we
do we're not going to cry and be like,
"Oh how dare
the messenger of Allah say this?" So,
look how she deals with it. Look what
she does next which is very interesting.
You know what? I'm going to call him
now.
Salam alaykum salam
Hey alaykum salam. How you doing? Good
alhamdulillah.
I just wanted to say how much I love you
and how much I appreciate you.
And I'm really grateful for the
everything that you do for me.
Alhamdulillah. What's going on?
Nothing. I just wanted to say that I'm
grateful for you. What do you want LJ?
Hey you know what it what it what a wife
calls it like it is like you know listen
I'm not that listen when my wife calls
me yeah
and she's like, "You know
you're an amazing husband or this that
whatever whatever." Okay, I've got my
little shortcomings, coming as well yeah
between each other, but you know, she
calls and she's like, "You know, I just
wanted to say that I love you." I'm
like, "Nah, bro, this is going
somewhere." I'm like, "Yeah, okay." This
time I'm like, "Yeah, okay, love you,
too. Yeah, okay, what next?" You know,
it was it it it Okay, okay, yeah, same,
same. Okay, and I'm waiting.
And she doesn't say anything. I'm like,
You don't You don't You don't You don't
want money or something? Like or etc.
Okay, so it's a joke. It is like It's
like Okay, it's it's it's just pure
call. Just just just wanted to Yeah. Do
you get it? Cuz someone is like, "Okay,
do you need something? You want to buy
something? It's a little bit expensive.
What's going on?" Yeah, so I I find it
hilarious. He's like He's like, "Yo,
okay, what's going on?" And then he
said, "Okay." Nothing. I don't want
anything.
I JUST WANTED TO SAY I'm grateful.
There you go. You know You know what
that shows? It's very interesting
though. Like subhanallah, it's um
sometimes I'm not saying it's to the
lady or whatever etc. But sometimes as
men we are cuz men are the only ones
that are
loved conditionally. Children, women,
even dogs are loved unconditionally. We
as men, uh sadly, and that's why I say
to a lot of sisters watching this, if
you're watching this,
um try to stay cuz as men There's even
studies show subhanallah men perform
like even when it comes to monetary
stuff etc. when good words come out
their wife's mouth, when they are
being supported by their wife. So,
sisters, don't underestimate how much it
means cuz we carry the world on our
shoulders. We don't cry. We don't come
and cry, but believe me, we carry the
world on our shoulders. And sometimes
good words just Well, I believe that
there. And sometimes that's where we're
like, "Okay, when they call us they're
like, 'Okay, is there something they
want?'" You know why? Because to us it
shows us the the the the ex- not the
expectation, but the desire and like how
much we are we were thriving or wanting
just to be acknowledged. And this is why
even a study showed men who were in
mental hospitals when World War broke
out and they were given a purpose, they
were driving ambulances and stuff like
that. When they are given a role and
they are found as needy, they're being
they're being wanted, their mind
shifted. And that's with us. We want to
be wanted by our wives just the way you
like to be wanted and needed by your
babies. Like when you have a baby you
like you love the fact that your baby
needs you, wants you. That's how we are
with our wives. Subhanallah. But let's
carry on.
No, I saw this video on TikTok and I
were like talking about a hadith that
great ungrateful wives go to hell. So, I
just wanted to get my ticket to Jannah.
Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. Got you.
Alhamdulillah.
I appreciate you guys, too. Love it.
Bye.
Did you see that? Did she have a fit?
Did she have like how dare that hadith?
I reject hadith. I would have become
become a kafir. Yes, if you reject
hadiths. Yes? Nope. She said, "That's
what the messenger of Allah said?"
It does sound harsh and it is harsh.
There's a reason why it is, okay?
Because the prophet knows things we
don't know. When the prophet does things
Allah says in the Quran against us men
is harsh. But we don't come and say no,
we say okay, there must be a reason.
Maybe we have inclinations to sometimes
run away from the battlefield. Now,
argue with me. Yes, we need to fight
that. Do you get it? So, I appreciate
and subhanallah I big up sister Lilly
Jay for this. You know why? Because at
the end of the day, look, she enacted
and said, "You know what? I'm going to
call and I appreciate the reminder
video. Okay, I'm not going to say this
is fake. No, I'm so sorry. She called
and showed her gratitude
to her husband. Now, you might come and
say, "Oh, it's for the camera." Cut the
nonsense. Assume the best. Look what she
done. This is key here. And this is
someone that some sisters would deem a
non-hijabi might be dressing a bit
whatever whatever whatever and they
would say all kind of stuff. Wallahi,
this sister, it might be that the
external fitna is her only issue and she
knows it's a sin. She knows I'm not
going to come and quote to her like,
"No, no, it's a sin." Yes? Okay? And I
believe there is a journey with a
context. Those who are saying it's a
journey and not wanting to wear it, no.
I'm with Akhi Ayman with that all day
every day. Anyone that's using it
genuinely and which I know Akhi Ayman
has no issue, a journey in the sense
where you are like, okay, I'm taking
steps. Yes, I can even issue as well
with those who are taking the mic. For
example, if a man is watching
pornography and he says it's a journey.
Brother, a journey for what? 2 years?
What kind of journey are you having?
It's going to end this journey. That's
what we're talking about. So, I just
wanted to react to that guys, inshallah.
And may Allah subhana wa ta'ala protect
our sisters and make us those who
internally submit and are true and
believe in the heart. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.